this footage shows El Salvador's answer
to gang violence thousands of alleged
gang members stripped down to expose
their tattoos in a brand new Mega prison
set to house 40 000 inmates
[Music]
gangs turned El Salvador's murder rate
into one of the highest in the world and
to end this cycle of violence the
country's President najib bukele ordered
a Crackdown in March last year arresting
more than 66 thousand people since then
communities say the streets are safer
but rights groups and some residents
argue that this change has come at a
high price that innocent men and women
and even miners have been rounded up and
held indefinitely without access to
lawyers
I'm here in El Salvador to gauge the
impact of this effort what it means for
families and communities and for a
Central American country that has been
gripped by gang violence for decades
stoking both poverty and migration
towards the U.S
in El Salvador a country the size of
Massachusetts and with a population of
6.3 million the violence has been blamed
on the MS-13 and the 18th street gangs
groups that originated among Salvadorans
in the U.S in the 1980s they terrorized
communities for decades in El Salvador
demanding weekly extortion payments from
business owners and imposing curfews in
2015 El Salvador's murder rate was over
100 per 100 000 people but by 2022
officials said the number went down to
7.8
serious
president najib bukele imposed a state
of emergency where lawmakers suspended
constitutional guarantees allowing
soldiers to raid communities in search
of anyone with suspected gang ties
the mass arrests gave El Salvador the
world's highest incarceration rate as
one percent of the national population
has been put behind bars over the past
year
[Music]
as a result of the Crackdown gang
members are no longer prevalent in
communities small businesses can Now
operate without fear and at any time of
the day without having to pay high
extortion fees
but the offensive fractured many of the
poorest households tens of thousands of
young children have had at least one
parent or caregiver detained under the
declared state of emergency Ana mancia
says her four adult children were
working as Street vendors when they were
detained last year
she was left to take care of six
grandchildren none of them go to school
and Anna struggles to feed them
families like Anna's can't afford legal
representation
Alejandro Diaz Gomez is a non-profit
attorney he advises 250 families of
detainees who he says are wrongfully
held impossible
families Young
humano
rights groups say people are locked up
in crowded cells with little food while
they wait indefinitely for trial
[Music]
this man told us his two sons were
arrested during the Crackdown last year
El Salvador's security minister Gustavo
viadoro denied allegations of Human
Rights abuses and arbitrary detentions
adding that all gang members will spend
the rest of their lives behind bars
more than a year into the Crackdown
president bukela's approval rating is at
a record high
polls at the start of the Year showed
more than 90 percent of Salvadorans are
happy with the president's security
effort and El Salvador's model has drawn
the attention of other Latin American
countries gripped by violent crime such
as Ecuador and Honduras
political analysts say the crackdown's
popularity could pave the way for bukele
to seek re-election next year while the
country's Constitution does not allow a
president to have consecutive terms in
office he has said he plans to run again
foreign